who's ready for an exciting countdown to
2022 i'm actor host comedian michael yo
you may have seen me on america's got
talent oh michael you were so good you
put the tea in talent and hello
everybody i am nikki novak i am a
television host from
this is my home los angeles california
where there is also a lot of talent now
we're going to be counting it down in
every time zone in my beautiful home las
vegas we're going to be watching all the
great parties from the beautiful
the gorgeous
resorts hotel and casino
you said beautiful and gorgeous well
never mind you know what's better than
one party michael yo what's that four
parties we are going to be counting down
the new year from four different time
zones we're gonna be kicking it off from
times square and that famous ball drop
we're then gonna be going to dallas and
denver with some amazing fireworks shows
and then finally the fabulous las vegas
where we're gonna watch fireworks from
seven hotel rooftops and we haven't even
got to the entertainment yet performing
live from american idol scotty mcqueery
you may know him from his hit song five
more minutes i've already had my 15
minutes never mind
[Music]
no no no no we don't know please don't
put your leg up blue man group will be
there as well
hi this is zoe bowie coming to you live
from
elvis's iconic dressing room here at the
west gate las vegas we are so excited to
spend new year's eve 2022 with all of
you see you then
well we want you to join in on the party
as well we want you when you use that
social media use the hashtag vegas n-y-e
we're gonna be checking out all your
party pics whether you're with your crew
or your solo doing the selfie thing like
i do a lot yeah check it out countdown
to 2022 is going to be airing on 14
different stations all owned by nexstar
they're all down the west coast across
the southwest and you can also stream it
on their websites so
please join us as we bring in the new
year we cannot wait to see you we can't
wait we'll see you we'll see it we're
ready
i'm ready i'm wearing sequins yeah she
is she's already ready